This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Quignote our episode today is really fun and joyful, but it does include talk about sex and mentions of sexual violence, so use discretion. When producer Katie Mingle's mom, Pam Mingle, retired from a long career as a fifth grade teacher, she started writing books. First, she published a time travel novel for young adults. Then, she wrote a Jane Austen spin-off novel, and eventually, she decided to write a romance. My mom, a huge Jane Austen fan, took a page from her favorite author and set her first romance during the Regency period in England, so around 1812. The plot involves two people who start out as
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我们要提醒大家，今天的节目非常有趣且令人愉悦，但其中确实涉及了关于性的话题，并提到了性暴力，请谨慎收听。当制作人凯蒂·明格尔的母亲帕姆·明格尔结束了长达多年的五年级教师生涯退休后，她开始写书。起初，她出版了一部面向年轻人的时间旅行小说。后来，她写了一部简·奥斯汀的衍生小说，最终，她决定写一部浪漫小说。我母亲是简·奥斯汀的超级粉丝，她从自己最喜欢的作家那里汲取灵感，将她的第一部浪漫小说背景设定在英国摄政时期，大约是1812年。情节涉及两个最初是
friends, Cass and Adam, and get engaged because Adam needs a reason not to marry someone that his family wants him to marry. Cass and Adam aren't in love and they don't necessarily plan on actually getting married. But then... They start to fall for each other and of course there are many many obstacles in their path which they have to overcome. That is of course my mom. I'm Pam Mangel. I am the writer of six published books, four of which are romances. In 2015 a small publisher called Entangled bought my mom's first romance manuscript. They decided on the title of False Proposal, and eventually they also came up with a cover design for the book, which they showed my mom.
朋友的人，卡斯和亚当，他们订婚是因为亚当需要一个理由，不去娶他家人希望他娶的人。卡斯和亚当并没有相爱，他们也不一定打算真的结婚。但是后来……他们开始爱上对方，当然，他们面前有许多许多必须克服的障碍。那当然是我妈妈。我是帕姆·明格尔。我是六本已出版书籍的作者，其中四本是浪漫小说。2015年，一家名为Entangled的小型出版商买下了我母亲的第一部浪漫小说手稿。他们决定将书名定为《虚假求婚》，最终他们还为这本书设计了一个封面，并展示给了我母亲。
I believe they sent me, yes, they sent me an email that had the cover attached and said, it isn't just a beautiful cover? And we love it. And we hope that you will. Well, what did you think when he thought it? I thought it was lushly romantic, I guess, is what you could say. I think I was a little startled by the, you know, the bending backwards and the very sort of dramatic pose. I didn't necessarily expect that, but I thought it was beautiful, and I loved the colors.
我相信他们发给我，是的，他们发给我一封邮件，附件里有封面，并说，这难道不是一个美丽的封面吗？我们很喜欢它。我们希望你也会喜欢。那么，当你看到它时，你是怎么想的？我想你可以说它看起来非常浪漫。我想我被那种向后弯曲的姿势和那种非常戏剧性的造型吓了一跳。我并不一定预料到会是这样，但我认为它很美，而且我喜欢这些颜色。
The cover of the book is a deep, purply blue background, and it probably features an image of a man and a woman dressed in ballroom clothing. The man is clutching the woman's thigh, kind of pulling her leg up toward his hip and leaning her backwards, almost like he's laying her onto a bed. Their eyes are closed and their mouths are almost touching.
这本书的封面背景是深紫蓝色，上面可能印着一对穿着舞会服装的男女。男人紧紧抓住女人的大腿，把她的腿拉向自己的臀部，并让她向后倾斜，几乎就像要把她放在床上一样。他们闭着眼睛，嘴唇几乎触碰在一起。
The first time I saw this cover, I guess I was a little embarrassed. Like, I knew my mom had written her romance. I'd even read the manuscript, but I didn't realize it was going to have a cover like this. And what do you remember my reaction being? Well, I was... we were in the car somewhere. Your dad was driving, and I was relating a story
第一次看到这个封面时，我想我有点尴尬。就像，我知道我妈妈写了浪漫小说。我甚至读过手稿，但我没意识到它会有这样的封面。你还记得我的反应是什么吗？嗯，我当时……我们当时在车里。你爸爸在开车，我正在讲一个故事
of a friend of mine who had just said to me, wow, that book looks like a real bodice ripper. And generally romance writers don't like to have their books called bodice rippers. It just has all these connotations that romance writers don't like. One of which is sort of rape, you know. And I was relating this conversation to you and your dad. And then you said, I don't remember exactly what you said, but it was something like,
关于我的一个朋友，她刚对我说，哇，那本书看起来真像一本“撕衣小说”（bodice ripper）。通常浪漫小说作家不喜欢他们的书被称为“撕衣小说”。它带有一些浪漫小说作家不喜欢的内涵。其中之一就是某种强奸的意味，你知道的。我当时正在向你和你爸爸讲述这段对话。然后你说，我不记得你具体说了什么，但大概是这样的，
well, why do you have covers like that if you don't want people to think that? Ooh, okay, I don't remember saying that exact thing, but here's what I was thinking about the cover. I thought it was corny, and it didn't do justice to the strong writing and complicated characters inside the book. And also, yeah, I thought the dynamic, the dominant man, the submissive woman, was old-fashioned and kind of heteronormative.
嗯，如果你不想让人们那样想，为什么要有那样的封面呢？噢，好吧，我不记得我说了那句确切的话，但我当时对封面的想法是这样的。我觉得它很俗气，而且没有体现出书里强有力的写作和复杂的人物。而且，是的，我认为那种动态，占主导地位的男人和顺从的女人，是过时的，而且有点异性恋霸权。
I don't recall exactly what I said that day in the car, but I do remember registering that I'd hurt my mom's feelings. I remember just going completely quiet and not even responding to what you said because it really upset me. I'm sorry. I forgave you long ago for that. My mom may have forgiven me, but I still hadn't sorted it out. Like, was her cover and others like it, sending out signals that I just didn't like, or speaking a language I didn't speak? It all made me want to understand these covers better,
我不记得那天在车里我具体说了什么，但我确实记得我意识到我伤害了我妈妈的感情。我记得我完全沉默了，甚至没有回应你所说的话，因为这真的让我很难过。我很抱歉。我很久以前就原谅你了。我妈妈可能原谅了我，但我自己还没理清。比如，她的封面和其他类似的封面，是否在发出我不喜欢的信号，或者在说一种我不懂的语言？这一切让我想要更好地理解这些封面，
where they came from, and why my reaction to them was so negative. I think a good place to start with all of this might be what even is romance. Hi, my name is Sarah McLean and I'm a romance novelist. Someone told me I should talk to Sarah McLean about romance covers and the history of the genre more generally. That's why I reached out to her and And I swear I only learned after the fact that she had written a romance novel based on a 99% invisible episode.
它们来自哪里，以及为什么我对它们的反应如此负面。我认为这一切的一个很好的起点可能是，浪漫小说到底是什么。嗨，我叫莎拉·麦克莱恩，我是一名浪漫小说作家。有人告诉我，我应该和莎拉·麦克莱恩谈谈浪漫小说封面以及该类型的历史。这就是我联系她的原因，而且我发誓，我是在事后才知道她写过一部基于《99%隐形》某一集的浪漫小说。
I've been listening to 99% invisible forever, like forever. It was the perfect security episode. Episode 160, it's about lockpicking and designing an unpickable lock. When Sarah heard it, she had an idea for the heroine of her next novel. I was like, oh my God, she's gonna be a lock pick. I sort of put together this whole plan of like how this lady lock pick would pick an unpickable lock because of you.
我一直都在听《99%隐形》，就像永远都在听一样。那是完美的“安全”那一集。第160集，是关于开锁和设计一把无法被打开的锁。当莎拉听到那一集时，她为下一部小说的女主角想到了一个点子。我当时想，天哪，她要成为一个开锁匠。因为你，我构思了整个计划，关于这位女开锁匠如何打开一把无法打开的锁。
Anyway, Sarah says that the genre people called romance, the one my mom was writing in, it's always had a basic pact with the reader. I'm going to take you on this wild ride and there will be massive highs and massive lows, but at the end, they live happily ever after. The happily ever after were H.E.A., if you want to sound in the know, has always been a distinguishing feature of the genre. And by this definition alone, you could argue that someone like Jane Austen was basically a romance novelist, and some people do. But Sarah believes the modern era of romance really started in the 1970s, with a woman named Kathleen Woodowiss. And she described herself as a midwestern housewife. She lived with a husband who read adventure novels. And she would read the adventure novels that came into
总之，莎拉说，人们称之为浪漫小说的类型，也就是我妈妈正在写的那个类型，一直与读者有一个基本的契约。我要带你经历这段狂野的旅程，会有巨大的高潮和巨大的低谷，但最后，他们会幸福地生活在一起。如果你想显得很内行，可以称之为“HE”（Happily Ever After），这一直是该类型的一个显著特征。仅凭这个定义，你就可以说像简·奥斯汀这样的人基本上就是一位浪漫小说作家，有些人也确实这么认为。但莎拉认为，现代浪漫小说的时代真正始于20世纪70年代，一位名叫凯瑟琳·伍迪维斯的女性。她形容自己是一位中西部的家庭主妇。她和一位读冒险小说的丈夫住在一起。她会读那些随他一起进入
the house with him. And at one point she said, well, I don't understand why none of these have a woman as the adventurer at the center of the stories. So Kathleen Woodewis sat down and wrote one. It was called the Flame in the Flower and it was a romantic adventure story with a female protagonist and it had something else, something that would become another distinguishing feature of the genre. She has sex on page and real sex. She has like sex and achieves orgasm on page in like long form. I mean Elizabeth Bennett and Mr. Darcy could never. But the flame in the flower was also deeply problematic. In the flame in the flower, the hero rapes the heroin four times in the first 100 pages of the book.
家里的冒险小说。有一次她说，嗯，我不明白为什么这些书里没有一个女性作为故事中心的冒险家。于是凯瑟琳·伍迪维斯坐下来写了一本。书名叫《火焰与花》，这是一个以女性为主角的浪漫冒险故事，它还有别的东西，一些将成为该类型另一个显著特征的东西。她在书里写了性，而且是真实的性。她写了长篇的性爱过程，甚至包括高潮。我是说，伊丽莎白·班内特和达西先生永远不可能做到这一点。但《火焰与花》也存在严重的问题。在《火焰与花》中，男主角在书的前100页里强奸了女主角四次。
And the heroin in her own POV, her own point of view, names it rape, calls him a rapist, loaves him for the act, punishes him for the act, and Granted by the end, Marries him and lives happily ever after with him, which is problematic in 2021, but it wasn't 2021. in 2021, but it wasn't 2021. It was 1972 and whatever was happening in that book, it didn't keep people from buying it. It sold 2.3 million copies and it's first few years on the market.
而女主角在自己的视角中，将此称为强奸，称他为强奸犯，因这种行为而厌恶他，惩罚他，而且，当然，到最后，她嫁给了他，并与他幸福地生活在一起，这在2021年看来是有问题的，但在1972年，无论那本书里发生了什么，它并没有阻止人们购买它。它在上市的头几年就卖出了230万册。
Publishers were like, wait a second, women buy books. The floodgates were open and a lot of books similar to the flame and the flower hit the market. That is, historical romantic adventure stories that often included sexual violence. There was a lot of non-consensual ripping of bodices in those early books, hence the term bodice river, which obviously the genre continues to be saddled with to this day. bodice river, which obviously the genre continues to be saddled with to this day. But Sarah says even though there was rape in these books, they can't be completely dismissed and they aren't even necessarily anti-feminist. One thing about romance that's been true from the very beginning of the genre is that
出版商们心想，等一下，女性会买书。闸门打开了，许多类似于《火焰与花》的书籍涌入市场。也就是说，历史浪漫冒险故事，通常包含性暴力。在那些早期的书里，有很多非自愿的“撕衣”情节，因此有了“撕衣小说”这个词，显然，这个类型至今仍背负着这个词。但莎拉说，尽管这些书里有强奸情节，但它们不能被完全否定，甚至不一定是反女权主义的。关于浪漫小说，从该类型诞生之初就有一个事实，那就是
the women are always the heroes of their own stories. The heroines take action and claim their happiness. These books were the only place where women could see themselves and see the trauma that women in the world often have to deal with on the page and then also see themselves in triumph and in hope and in happiness and love. Like these are powerful, subversive ideas. Subversive ideas packaged with over the top sexy covers.
女性永远是她们自己故事中的英雄。女主角采取行动并争取自己的幸福。这些书是女性唯一能看到自己，看到世界上女性经常不得不面对的创伤，然后也能看到自己获得胜利、希望、幸福和爱情的地方。这些是强有力的、颠覆性的思想。这些颠覆性的思想被包装在夸张的性感封面上。
As the 70s rolled into the 80s, you really see the classic romance cover come into being, you know, the ones, like my mom's cover, but even sexier. A man and a woman, his abs glistening, her hair blowing in the wind, they're locked in a passionate embrace. The eighties were the heyday of the half-nude painted men, women with their bodices sort of half-off and gravity-defying hair.
随着70年代进入80年代，你真正看到了经典浪漫小说封面的诞生，你知道的，那些，就像我妈妈的封面，但更性感。一个男人和一个女人，他的腹肌闪闪发光，她的头发在风中飘扬，他们锁在热情的拥抱中。八十年代是半裸彩绘男人的全盛时期，女人们的衣服半脱，头发无视重力。
This type of cover became so ubiquitous in the romance genre that it got a name, the clinch. Clinch is an interesting word. It can mean to secure something like they clinch the deal, but the second definition comes from boxing. You know that thing that boxers do when they hug each other? That's called clenching. It's basically to keep your opponent from hurting you.
这种封面在浪漫小说类型中变得如此普遍，以至于它有了一个名字，叫“紧拥”（the clinch）。“Clinch”是一个有趣的词。它可以指确保某事，比如“敲定交易”（clinch the deal），但第二个定义来自拳击。你知道拳击手互相拥抱的那种动作吗？那叫“clinching”。它基本上是为了防止对手伤害你。
Fletters clinch, and on romance covers, lovers also clinch. In the 1980s, no one was doing a more epic clinch on her covers than the author Joanna Lindsay. She was the biggest name in romance during this time. In 1985, Joanna Lindsay published a romance called Tender is the Storm, and the cover is really a sight to behold. It's by an illustrator named Robert McGonness, and it's a painted image of a man and a woman
拳击手会“clinch”，而在浪漫小说封面上，恋人们也会“clinch”。在20世纪80年代，没有人比作家乔安娜·林赛在封面上做出的“紧拥”更史诗了。她是那个时期浪漫小说界最大的名字。1985年，乔安娜·林赛出版了一部名为《温柔是风暴》的浪漫小说，封面确实令人叹为观止。它是由一位名叫罗伯特·麦金尼斯（Robert McGinnis）的插画家绘制的，这是一幅男人和女人的彩绘图像
in a clinch. They're outside in some sort of desert landscape, and the man is 100% naked. He's fully nude, and like backed into some sort of sagebrush or something. The man's nether parts are conveniently hidden by the woman who's collapsed against his body in a full swoon. Like she's completely limp and literally appears to be unconscious. She's just lost to him. I mean, just ravished by him.
处于“紧拥”状态。他们在某种沙漠景观的户外，男人是100%赤裸的。他全裸，背靠着某种灌木丛之类的东西。男人的私处被倒在他怀里、完全昏厥的女人巧妙地遮住了。就像她完全瘫软，看起来真的失去了知觉。她只是沉浸在他身上。我是说，简直被他迷住了。
The man on this cover looks kind of like Clark Kent with short, wavy dark hair, but Joanna Lindsay would soon introduce the world to a blonde model who would become forever and ever, till death to them part, married to the genre of romance. So Fabio was on most of Joanna Lindsay's covers during this time period. I mean, he was on many other covers too, but he was the hallmark of a Joanna Lindsay cover. You know, he was a big guy, and he was a very nice and gentle person. This is an illustrator named Max Ginsburg, who worked with Fabio a few times in his career. The way he covers were made back in the 80s was that models like Fabio would pose for a photo shoot and then an illustrator like Max would render that photo
这个封面上的男人看起来有点像克拉克·肯特，留着短而卷曲的深色头发，但乔安娜·林赛很快就会向世界介绍一位金发模特，他将永远、永远，直到死亡将他们分开，与浪漫小说类型结合在一起。所以法比奥（Fabio）在这一时期乔安娜·林赛的大多数封面上都有出现。我是说，他也出现在许多其他封面上，但他是一个乔安娜·林赛封面的标志。你知道，他是个大块头，是一个非常友善和温柔的人。这是一位名叫马克斯·金斯伯格（Max Ginsburg）的插画家，他在职业生涯中与法比奥合作过几次。80年代封面制作的方式是，像法比奥这样的模特会为照片拍摄摆姿势，然后像马克斯这样的插画家会将那张照片
into a painting, adding a new background like a beach or a meadow. But Max was there in the photo shoots too. I was sitting there like the director in the movie. You know, hold the girl a little more firmly or a little more tenderly or whatever, you know. And we have a procedure a little bit like Norman Rockwell had where you would trace the images from the photographs. And then once you did that, then you would start to paint. Max says he
渲染成一幅画，添加一个新的背景，比如海滩或草地。但马克斯也在拍摄现场。我当时就像电影里的导演一样坐在那里。你知道，让女孩抱得更紧一点，或者更温柔一点，等等，你知道的。我们有一个类似于诺曼·洛克威尔（Norman Rockwell）的程序，你会从照片中描摹图像。一旦你做到了这一点，你就会开始绘画。马克斯说他
never understood why Fabio became such a big thing. I thought that actually, honestly, he was much of an actor. You know, he didn't know exactly how to project themselves. It's just a big overpower looking guy. But for some reason, he made it big. In some ways though, in being a rather unimodative brute, Fabio was getting his role exactly right.
从不明白为什么法比奥会变得如此出名。我当时想，老实说，他并不是一个很好的演员。你知道，他不知道如何准确地投射自己。他只是一个看起来很强壮的大块头。但出于某种原因，他成功了。然而在某些方面，作为一个相当迟钝的野蛮人，法比奥确实把他的角色演对了。
If you read the books of the 70s and early 80s, heroes are impenetrable. They are blank slates of just kind of intense masculine pride and arrogance, and they lack a capacity for emotion and for feeling and they're ciphers. In any case, Fabio and other hyper-masculine men in passionate embraces with their leading ladies were plastered all over romance covers in the 1980s. And wrapping the books in these covers, really it did two things in my opinion. One, it said, this is the book you're getting, right? You're going to get a woman who is, you know, in touch with her sexual identity and in touch with
如果你读70年代和80年代初的书，英雄们是不可逾越的。他们是空白的石板，只有强烈的男性自豪感和傲慢，他们缺乏情感和感觉的能力，他们是密码。无论如何，法比奥和其他超阳刚的男人与女主角热烈拥抱的形象在20世纪80年代的浪漫小说封面上随处可见。在我看来，用这些封面包装书籍确实做了两件事。第一，它说，这就是你得到的书，对吧？你会得到一个与自己的性身份和
her pleasure and the center of the story, and she's going to triumph at the end, and you'll be able to read this and explore safely your own fantasies. And also the cover said, men keep out. This isn't for you, which both increased the likelihood that women would buy these books and also increased the level of disdain that society started to have for these books. Because if they're for women, then surely they can't have value. You can hear the contempt that the larger culture had
快乐保持联系，并且是故事中心的女人，她最终会取得胜利，你将能够阅读这本书并安全地探索你自己的幻想。而且封面还说，男人止步。这不是给你们看的，这既增加了女性购买这些书的可能性，也增加了社会开始对这些书所持有的蔑视程度。因为如果它们是给女性看的，那么它们肯定没有价值。你可以听到主流文化对
for romance in this episode of Nightline from the 1980s. The segment is one part news about the success of the genre and one part unsolicited lecture. These products have about as much to do with classical literature as Big Macs have to do with three-star French cooking. But of course not everybody likes which sophisticated food. So if William Faulkner or Arnaest Hemingway gives you a heartburn, then these birds could just be your mate. Here's Brad for Nightline and Washington. When we return, we'll talk live with two women who make their living off romance novels
浪漫小说的蔑视，在80年代的《夜线》（Nightline）节目中。这一片段一部分是关于该类型成功的新闻，另一部分是未经请求的讲座。这些产品与古典文学的关系，就像巨无霸与三星级法国烹饪的关系一样。但当然不是每个人都喜欢这种精致的食物。所以如果威廉·福克纳或欧内斯特·海明威让你胃灼热，那么这些书可能就是你的菜。这是华盛顿《夜线》的布拉德。回来后，我们将与两位靠写浪漫小说为生的人进行现场交谈，
and understandably think there's more to the John Wilden titillating trash. And later, I'll look at some of the historic accomplishments this week aboard the Space Shuttle Challenger. Oh, yikes. Through the years, people like Ted Coppill and his correspondent, and God, I guess, maybe me, have found lots of reasons to look down on romance. Romance is formulating, predictable, badly written. The genre is very used to being judged on the whole. Julia Quinn, who wrote Bridgerton,
她们理所当然地认为，除了煽情的垃圾，这个类型还有更多内涵。稍后，我将回顾本周在挑战者号航天飞机上的一些历史性成就。噢，天哪。多年来，像泰德·科佩尔（Ted Koppel）和他的记者，以及上帝，我想，也许还有我，都找到了很多看不起浪漫小说的理由。浪漫小说是公式化的、可预测的、写得很烂的。这个类型非常习惯于被整体评判。朱莉娅·奎因（Julia Quinn），《布里奇顿》（Bridgerton）的作者，
one of the things that she says a lot, and I think is really valuable, is other genres get judged on the very best of their writing, and romance gets judged on the very worst of it. Often, romance gets dinged for so many unfair things that I think are almost entirely related to patriarchy. Did I not respond well to romance and romance covers because of straight-up sexism? I mean, that feels possible. I'm not dismissing it. But I think also, maybe through most of my life growing up as a queer person, I just didn't see myself in those clinches. And I wasn't
她经常说的一件事，我认为非常有价值，那就是其他类型是根据它们最好的作品来评判的，而浪漫小说是根据它最差的作品来评判的。通常，浪漫小说因为许多不公平的事情而受到指责，我认为这些事情几乎完全与父权制有关。我没有很好地回应浪漫小说和浪漫小说封面，是因为纯粹的性别歧视吗？我是说，这感觉是有可能的。我并没有否定它。但我认为，也许在我作为一个酷儿成长的过程中，我只是没有在那些“紧拥”中看到自己。而且我不是
the only one who didn't. It was usually, why couples on the cover? This is Nicole Perkins. She writes about pop culture, hosts a podcast called This is Good for You, and is a long-time reader of romance. Even though as a young black person in the 1980s, she also didn't see herself in the covers. And what I would do is I would stay away from blonde people. If there were blonde people on the cover, I did not pick those up.
唯一一个没有看到自己的人。通常是，为什么封面上是白人夫妇？这是妮可·珀金斯（Nicole Perkins）。她撰写关于流行文化的文章，主持一个名为《这对你有好处》（This is Good for You）的播客，并且是一位长期的浪漫小说读者。尽管作为80年代的一名年轻黑人，她也没有在封面上看到自己。我当时会做的是，我会远离金发碧眼的人。如果封面上有人是金发，我就不会拿起那些书。
So I picked up, I would pick up the covers with dark-haired white people, because I would pretend that they were black and just very fair-skinned. In 1974, a writer named Anne Shockley put out a lesbian interracial romance called Loving Her. But you'd have had a hard time finding it in any mainstream bookstores. her, but you'd have had a hard time finding it in any mainstream bookstores. And then in 1980, a black editor at Down in Vivian Stevens published a few black heterosexual romances. But by and large, the genre was white and straight, and the early black romances tended to be a little more chased.
所以我拿起的是，我会拿起深色头发白人的封面，因为我会假装他们是黑人，只是皮肤非常白皙。1974年，一位名叫安妮·肖克利（Anne Shockley）的作家出版了一部名为《爱她》（Loving Her）的同性恋跨种族浪漫小说。但你在任何主流书店都很难找到它。然后在1980年，一位名叫薇薇安·斯蒂芬斯（Vivian Stephens）的黑人编辑出版了几部黑人异性恋浪漫小说。但总的来说，这个类型是白人和异性恋的，早期的黑人浪漫小说往往比较保守。
Yeah, if I recall correctly, sex seemed to be more alluded to because I remember that was also part of my frustration with the early black romances that I read. You know, I was a pre-team and then an adolescent, so I wanted to get stuff. But then came the author Beverly Jenkins. She was definitely a big deal. Beverly Jenkins is black and she writes deeply researched historical romances featuring black characters. And while her sex scenes in those early books weren't extremely explicit, they weren't completely hidden behind a closed door either. She also gave the world the first truly steamy clinch cover featuring black characters,
是的，如果我没记错的话，性似乎更多是被暗示的，因为我记得这也是我对我读过的早期黑人浪漫小说感到沮丧的一部分。你知道，我当时是青春期前，然后是青少年，所以我想要看那些东西。但后来出现了作家贝弗利·詹金斯（Beverly Jenkins）。她绝对是个大人物。贝弗利·詹金斯是黑人，她撰写经过深入研究的、以黑人角色为特色的历史浪漫小说。虽然她在那些早期书中的性爱场景并不极其露骨，但它们也没有完全隐藏在紧闭的门后。她还向世界展示了第一部真正火辣的、以黑人角色为特色的“紧拥”封面，
and she kept going, book after after book with black people in passionate embraces on the covers. To see those covers, I mean obviously at the time people were still, you know, kind of teasing women for reading romances and things like that, but it was still also a point of pride to be able to showcase a book with black people in these kind of very intimate, expressive embraces that were clearly indicating there's some physical intimacy here and somebody is going to be, you know, kissed along their spine at some point. Over the next couple of decades, romance would continue to change with the times. Rape scenes disappeared almost entirely.
而且她一本接一本，书的封面上都是黑人热情的拥抱。看到那些封面，我是说显然当时人们仍然在拿女性读浪漫小说开玩笑，但这仍然是一种骄傲，能够展示一本封面上是黑人进行这种非常亲密、富有表现力的拥抱的书，这清楚地表明这里有一些身体上的亲密关系，而且有人会在某个时候沿着他们的脊椎被亲吻。在接下来的几十年里，浪漫小说将继续随时代而改变。强奸场景几乎完全消失了。
The women in the books got more assertive, and the men got in touch with their emotions. And although the industry would remain predominantly white and straight, it's not nearly as white and as straight as before, which means the clinch cover has been claimed by more and more kinds of people. I'm thinking about cat Sebastian's books. Cat Sebastian's romances are often about queer characters and feature those characters in very classic looking clinches on the cover. There's something so awesome about seeing the clench, but queer, right? Yes.
书中的女性变得更加自信，男人也开始接触自己的情感。虽然这个行业仍然以白人和异性恋为主，但它不像以前那么白、那么直了，这意味着“紧拥”封面已经被越来越多的人所认领。我想到凯特·塞巴斯蒂安（Cat Sebastian）的书。凯特·塞巴斯蒂安的浪漫小说通常是关于酷儿角色的，并且在封面上以非常经典的“紧拥”姿势呈现这些角色。看到“紧拥”但却是酷儿的，这真是太棒了，对吧？是的。
This is our time for the clench to be owned by everyone, because there's no doubt that obviously the clench is exclusionary for, was exclusionary for many, many years. The style of the clinch covers has changed too. The images aren't rendered into paintings anymore. They're photographs. I'll be it. Photographs that have been worked over in Photoshop. Abs have never had more definition. Covers aren't all clinches anymore either.
这是我们让每个人都拥有“紧拥”的时候了，因为毫无疑问，“紧拥”在很多很多年里显然是排外的。“紧拥”封面的风格也发生了变化。图像不再被渲染成绘画。它们是照片。尽管是经过Photoshop处理的照片。腹肌的轮廓从未如此清晰。封面也不再全是“紧拥”了。
There are lots of variations. Like now you might just have a single figure on the cover, like a man in a kiln with a shirt off, or a woman in a dress throwing you a sultry glance over her shoulder. There are lots of kinds of covers, probably because there are so many kinds of romances. There are Scottish Highlander romances and Amish romances. There are thrillers and vampires and shape shifters. And Romance readers are plowing through these books as fast as publishers can get them on the shelves.
有很多变化。比如现在封面上可能只有一个人物，比如一个穿着衬衫、在窑炉里的男人，或者一个穿着裙子、从肩膀上向你投来妩媚一瞥的女人。有很多种封面，可能是因为有太多种浪漫小说。有苏格兰高地浪漫小说和阿米什浪漫小说。有惊悚片、吸血鬼和变形者。浪漫小说读者翻阅这些书的速度，和出版商把它们摆上书架的速度一样快。
Romance readers are voracious. And we read on average 10 to 12 books a month. Notice the universal we in that sentence. That's because Romance readers and writers really are kind of a big community that goes to conferences and meetups and has a surprising amount of kinship. And, you know, also a bit of infighting and controversy, but a kinship nonetheless with a shared language, some of which is coded in the covers themselves. If you show me or any romance reader, a series of covers they'll be able to tell you like that's a paranormal, that's a medieval, that's a Regency, that's a contemporary rom-com.
浪漫小说读者是贪婪的。我们平均每月阅读10到12本书。注意那句话里的通用“我们”。这是因为浪漫小说读者和作家确实是一个大社区，他们参加会议和聚会，有着令人惊讶的亲缘关系。而且，你知道，也有一些内斗和争议，但无论如何，这是一种有着共同语言的亲缘关系，其中一些语言本身就编码在封面上。如果你给我或任何浪漫小说读者看一系列封面，他们就能告诉你，那是超自然题材，那是中世纪题材，那是摄政时期题材，那是当代浪漫喜剧。
Nicole Perkins is particularly good at this game. Okay, so when I see a bear chested man, like maybe his face isn't even in the shot, it's just torso. I know that it's going to be a fairly steamy romance. And if it's like a blue background, the hero is some kind of law enforcement or a military person or something like that. And then the green background or a yellow background or like kind of a goldish, then I know there's probably gonna be some sort of paranormal element to it.
妮可·珀金斯特别擅长这个游戏。好吧，当我看到一个赤裸上身的男人，可能他的脸甚至不在镜头里，只是躯干。我就知道这将是一部相当火辣的浪漫小说。如果背景是蓝色的，英雄通常是某种执法人员或军人之类的。然后是绿色背景或黄色背景，或者像金色之类的，那么我就知道可能会有某种超自然元素。
Like maybe he's some kind of werewolf or were tiger. And that's just some of the signaling for paranormal and contemporary romances. For historicals, Nicole says, it can be a little trickier to figure out where you're getting. But I have found that, again, it's not full proof, but I have found that if there is, like, if the cover is lavender or a lot of purple
比如他可能是某种狼人或虎人。这只是超自然和当代浪漫小说的一些信号。对于历史题材，妮可说，弄清楚你会得到什么可能会有点棘手。但我发现，虽然不是万无一失，但我发现如果封面是薰衣草色或有很多紫色
or some very deep blues, then there's going to be some explicit sex or, you know, something that's really kind of steamy. Well, it's funny, you should say that because my mom's first romance novel actually has a purpley blue cover. When I think about what a book cover is supposed to do, it feels like generally the answer is like get people like me to pick it up and maybe buy it. But I had this realization talking to Nicole and Sarah. The covers aren't necessarily
或者一些非常深的蓝色，那么就会有一些露骨的性爱，或者你知道，一些非常火辣的内容。嗯，你说得很有趣，因为我妈妈的第一部浪漫小说确实有一个紫蓝色的封面。当我想到书的封面应该做什么时，感觉答案通常是让像我这样的人拿起它，也许买下它。但我与妮可和莎拉交谈后有了这个认识。封面并不一定
trying to appeal to me, Katie Mingle, and outsider to the genre. I feel like part of what you're saying is that like romance covers, they're not trying to get me to read them exactly. They're trying to get all the people who are already in this genre to sort of choose this particular one. Yes. The cover doesn't have to say like, hey, what's in here is also smart and feminist and thoughtful. Because romance readers already know that. say, like, hey, what's in here is also smart and feminist and thoughtful. Because romance readers already know that. It just has to say, you love most of the other books that have covers like this, so try this one too.
试图吸引我，凯蒂·明格尔，这个类型的外行。我觉得你所说的一部分是，浪漫小说封面，它们并不是真的想让我去读它们。它们是想让所有已经在这一类型中的人选择这一本。是的。封面不需要说，嘿，这里面的内容也很聪明、女权主义且发人深省。因为浪漫小说读者已经知道了。它只需要说，你喜欢大多数有这样封面的书，所以也试试这一本吧。
But the target audience for romance covers might be changing. In the last decade, illustrated covers have become more prevalent. Okay, so not to be confused with those classic covers that were paintings of real people, and in illustrated cover the figures are much more cartoonish and abstract, like something you'd see in a graphic novel. The vibe is more cute than sexy, and they've become more and more popular. For example, a book like Be Trade by Emily Henry.
但浪漫小说封面的目标受众可能正在改变。在过去十年中，插画封面变得越来越普遍。好吧，不要与那些作为真人绘画的经典封面混淆，在插画封面上，人物更加卡通化和抽象，就像你在漫画小说中看到的那样。氛围更可爱而不是性感，而且它们变得越来越受欢迎。例如，像艾米丽·亨利（Emily Henry）的《海滩读物》（Beach Read）这样的书。
Be Trade's cover features an illustration of a man and woman, but they're not in a clench. In fact, they're just kind of sitting on different sides of the cover. In between them and big white lettering is the title of the book. It really looks like it could be any other piece of contemporary fiction. It, you know, sat on the New York Times list. It's a straight up romance novel, but it really lingered on those lists because the cover doesn't look like a romance novel cover at all.
《海滩读物》的封面是一幅男人和女人的插画，但他们并没有“紧拥”。事实上，他们只是坐在封面的不同侧面。在他们之间，用白色大字写着书名。它看起来确实像任何其他当代小说。它，你知道，登上了《纽约时报》榜单。这是一部纯粹的浪漫小说，但它之所以能在榜单上停留那么久，是因为封面看起来根本不像浪漫小说封面。
You know, this is a way to get romance in front of the eyes of people who might not ever walk into the romance section. Sarah says that a lot of in-lead booksellers don't carry romance at all. And in more mainstream bookstores, the romance section is usually hidden way in the back. In mine in Brooklyn, the romance section is in the literal furthest place from the door.
你知道，这是一种让浪漫小说出现在那些可能永远不会走进浪漫小说区的人眼中的方式。莎拉说，很多独立书商根本不经营浪漫小说。而在更主流的书店里，浪漫小说区通常隐藏在后面。在我布鲁克林的那个书店里，浪漫小说区在离门口最远的地方。
Illustrated covers are an attempt to sort of trojan horse romance novels into the general fiction section. And win Win over readers who would maybe be a little bit embarrassed to buy a book with a clinch cover Well, maybe people like you would be more willing to pick up a romance novel if it didn't have a clinch on the cover She's calling you out mingle. I feel so bad that I was one of Don't worry about it. I really do. Like now, I'm just like, what was wrong with me? The thing is maybe illustrated covers
插画封面是一种试图将浪漫小说“特洛伊木马”式地引入一般小说区的方式。并赢得那些可能因为买一本有“紧拥”封面的书而感到尴尬的读者。好吧，也许像你这样的人如果封面没有“紧拥”会更愿意拿起浪漫小说。她在呼唤你，明格尔。我真为自己曾经是……别担心。我真的。就像现在，我只是想，我当时怎么了？问题是也许插画封面
can bring new people like me into the genre, but the people already there, they are not necessarily thrilled about this new direction. All of that coding that the classic romance cover does to tell romance diehards what they're getting, it's kind of lost in the illustrated covers. It's getting a bit difficult to figure out, is this women's fiction? Is this adult romance? Is this YA? This is the romance writer and reader Alyssa Cole. Alyssa has written several romances featuring black, queer, and other marginalized characters. Beyond sending out a quick
可以把像我这样的新人带入这个类型，但已经在那里的人，他们并不一定对这个新方向感到兴奋。经典浪漫小说封面用来告诉浪漫小说死忠粉他们会得到什么的那些编码，在插画封面上有点丢失了。现在很难弄清楚，这是女性小说吗？这是成人浪漫小说吗？这是YA（青少年小说）吗？这是浪漫小说作家和读者艾丽莎·科尔（Alyssa Cole）。艾丽莎写过几部以黑人、酷儿和其他边缘化角色为特色的浪漫小说。除了向读者发送关于书内内容的快速
signal to readers about what's inside the book, Alyssa believes one of the romance covers most important functions is to say, hey you, person who has not always been depicted in romantic stories, loves for you too. So she likes the covers where you can clearly make out people's features. Sometimes in the illustrated ones, you can't. You know, a lot of these covers have illustrations with no faces. My main thing is I'm fine with doing an illustrated cover,
信号外，艾丽莎认为浪漫小说封面最重要的功能之一是说，嘿，你，那个并不总是出现在浪漫故事中的人，这里也有属于你的爱。所以她喜欢那些能清楚辨认出人物特征的封面。有时在插画封面上，你做不到。你知道，很多这些封面上的插画都没有脸。我的主要观点是，我没问题做插画封面，
but you absolutely have to be able to tell that the book is about people of color. Alyssa Cole doesn't want to lose clench covers. She just wants them to become even more inclusive. I love clench covers. I love covers where people look like they're in love, which is what romance novels are about. Look, I know that I started out this journey saying clinch covers were corny and old fashioned. And to be honest, I still see some of that in those images.
但你绝对必须能看出这本书是关于有色人种的。艾丽莎·科尔不想失去“紧拥”封面。她只是希望它们变得更加包容。我喜欢“紧拥”封面。我喜欢人们看起来像是在相爱的封面，这正是浪漫小说的意义所在。看，我知道我开始这段旅程时说“紧拥”封面俗气且过时。老实说，我仍然在那些图像中看到一些那种感觉。
But I see the covers, particularly the clinch covers, in a new way now, too. I see them as a type of marketing, yeah. But also, as almost a flag. A flag for a club in which membership has long been associated with a certain amount of shame, shame about desire and sex, and also shame about pleasure, because as we all well know, we are supposed to feel guilty about reading things for pleasure. Again, the one and only panmingle.
但我现在也以一种新的方式看待这些封面，特别是“紧拥”封面。我把它们看作是一种营销，是的。但也几乎像一面旗帜。一个俱乐部的旗帜，其成员资格长期以来与某种羞耻感联系在一起，对欲望和性的羞耻感，以及对快乐的羞耻感，因为正如我们所知，我们被认为应该为为了快乐而阅读东西感到内疚。再次，唯一的帕姆·明格尔。
Romance was so joyful. When I began reading it, I just got this sense of joyousness that I had never experienced really in other kinds of fiction. Certainly moments of that, but not to the degree of a romance. Still, even my romance writing mom used to feel a sense of guilt about reading romance. I kept telling myself you shouldn't keep reading these books. I don't know why I don't really know why or understand why I would feel that way. I guess because maybe I was just, I went through this period of just reading a lot of them.
浪漫小说是如此令人愉悦。当我开始阅读它时，我感受到了一种我从未在其他类型小说中真正体验过的快乐感。当然有那样的时刻，但没有达到浪漫小说的程度。尽管如此，即使是我写浪漫小说的妈妈也曾经对阅读浪漫小说感到内疚。我一直告诉自己，你不应该继续读这些书。我不知道为什么，我真的不知道为什么或不明白为什么我会那样想。我想也许是因为我经历了一段只读了很多这类书的时期。
And then I would quit for a while and then I would go back every time I would go back because I missed it, I missed feeling those great feelings that I got from reading romance. Now when I look at my mom's cover, that classic clinch pose, it feels different. It feels like a flag boldly planted, like keep making fun of us patriarchy, but we are out here enjoying ourselves. This story was produced by Katie Mingle and edited by Emmett Fitzgerald. When we come back, we'll hear from someone who has been in many a clinch cover photo shoot
然后我会停一段时间，然后我会回去，每次我回去是因为我想念它，我想念从阅读浪漫小说中获得的那种美妙感觉。现在当我看着我妈妈的封面，那个经典的“紧拥”姿势，感觉不同了。它感觉像是一面大胆插下的旗帜，就像，继续嘲笑我们吧，父权制，但我们在这里享受着自己。这个故事由凯蒂·明格尔制作，埃米特·菲茨杰拉德编辑。回来后，我们将听到一位曾参与过许多“紧拥”封面拍摄的人
on how to get complete strangers to clinch like they mean it. After this. So I'm back with producer Katie Mingle and there was one person that you couldn't fit into the story, but you wanted to tell us about her. Yeah, so she's actually the kind of person that just needs her own episode. Her name is Chris Noble and she's an art director at a publisher called Kensington. And that means that she's basically the person who designs book covers. And not just romance covers, but she's done a lot of romance covers over the years. When I came out of art school, I wanted to go into the biggest design studio and design
关于如何让完全陌生的人像他们是认真的那样“紧拥”。稍后。所以我又和制作人凯蒂·明格尔在一起了，有一个人你没能放进故事里，但你想告诉我们关于她的事。是的，她其实是那种需要自己那一集的人。她的名字叫克里斯·诺布尔（Chris Noble），她是肯辛顿（Kensington）出版社的艺术总监。这意味着她基本上是设计书封面的人。不仅是浪漫小说封面，而且她多年来做了很多浪漫小说封面。当我从艺术学校出来时，我想进入最大的设计工作室并设计
packaging, but I'm like Coca-Cola is Coca-Cola, you know? And so unlike books, every story to me is different. Every character brings something out of me that challenges me. But the art director job is also a hard one because you really have to please everyone. Everybody marketing publicity, sales, the editors, the publishers, the therapists of the publishers, the therapists of the author,
包装，但我心想，可口可乐就是可口可乐，你知道吗？所以不像书，对我来说每个故事都是不同的。每个角色都带出我身上挑战我的东西。但艺术总监的工作也很难，因为你真的必须取悦每个人。每个人，市场营销、宣传、销售、编辑、出版商、出版商的治疗师、作者的治疗师、
the dog of the author, and that one friend they have who's a graphic designer. And I'm sure every single one of those has their own opinion about what they want. Yeah, and basically like most of the time they want something that someone else already has. They show me samples of books that are already out and they go, I like this cover. I wanted to look like this. And I'm like, but your book is coming out two years from now. It's going to already look old. So what I do is I give them what they want. I design what I think they want. And then I go out and I do my thing.
作者的狗，以及他们那个做平面设计师的朋友。我相信他们每个人都有自己关于他们想要什么的意见。是的，基本上大多数时候他们想要别人已经拥有的东西。他们给我看已经出版的书的样本，然后说，我喜欢这个封面。我想要它看起来像这样。而我心想，但你的书是两年后才出版的。它到时候看起来已经过时了。所以我做的是，我给他们他们想要的。我设计我认为他们想要的。然后我出去做我自己的事。
Some books I lose out on and I'm like, okay, I might be wrong. And sales is right. Or or you know marketing is right And then there's some that I'm very adamant about and I'm like no trust me people are gonna come to this Yeah, and this is something we don't really talk about in the main story and I have my own experience with this But do authors usually get a say on what their covers look like at all? I think essentially that depends on how famous of an author you are. So how famous were you, Roman? I don't know.
有些书我失败了，我心想，好吧，我可能错了。销售是对的。或者你知道，市场营销是对的。然后有些我非常坚持，我心想，不，相信我，人们会来看这个的。是的，这是我们在主故事中没有真正谈论的事情，我自己也有过这种经历，但作者通常对他们的封面看起来是什么样有发言权吗？我认为这基本上取决于你是一位多么著名的作者。那么你有多出名，罗曼？我不知道。
I was famous enough. I think they definitely were trying to appeal to me, but it was very clear in the contract language that it was their decision, not mine. Right. In the end, I think publishers generally get the final word. But they also don't want to make their authors unhappy. I mean, it is their book, it's their baby. We don't just snatch it out their arms and go running. But yeah, appeasing authors can be a lot of work.
我足够出名。我想他们肯定是在试图吸引我，但在合同语言中非常清楚，这是他们的决定，而不是我的。对。最后，我认为出版商通常拥有最终决定权。但他们也不想让他们的作者不高兴。我是说，这是他们的书，这是他们的孩子。我们不会只是从他们怀里抢走它然后跑掉。但是的，安抚作者可能是一项繁重的工作。
There was a woman, an author, who I worked on her book cover, and everybody loved it, including her. but she took it to her psychic. Oh, no. And the psychic said that this wasn't right for her because this color was, I mean, and to the point that the psychic was like sending me messages. And the author would not budge because her psychic said, no matter what sales marketing publicity the editor the publisher said she was adamant that she did not want that cover and I changed the cover and the book became very successful. So I always worried about whether or not it was me or the psychic that actually designed the book right and made it work. It was her.
有一位女性，一位作者，我为她的书封面工作，每个人都喜欢它，包括她。但她把它带给了她的通灵师。噢，不。通灵师说这不适合她，因为这个颜色是，我是说，甚至到了通灵师给我发信息的程度。而作者不肯让步，因为她的通灵师说，无论销售、市场、宣传、编辑、出版商怎么说，她都坚持她不想要那个封面，我换了封面，那本书变得非常成功。所以我总是担心到底是我是还是通灵师真正设计了这本书并让它成功。是她。
Yeah, it was probably her. I'll call that a ball for her. Yeah, I was probably hair. I'll call that a ball for her. So over the years, Chris Noble has been in a lot of photo sheets for clinch covers. And she's full of interesting info, as you can imagine. Like this. The male models tend not to be as tall as the female models. So we have to put this dude who's supposed to be like this big punky cowboy on a box.
是的，可能是她。我称之为她的功劳。是的，我可能是头发。我称之为她的功劳。所以多年来，克里斯·诺布尔参与了很多“紧拥”封面的照片拍摄。正如你可以想象的那样，她充满了有趣的信息。比如这个。男模特往往没有女模特高。所以我们不得不把这个本该是那种大块头牛仔的家伙放在一个盒子上。
Why is that? Yeah, I mean, of course I asked that also. And basically it's because the men tend to do sports catalogs. Whereas the women tend to be kind of regular like fashion. Runway models. They're selected for being tall and can wear clothes like on Runway. And the men just have to be built. They're short and stocky and muscular.
为什么会这样？是啊，我的意思是，我当然也问过这个问题。基本上是因为男性通常拍摄体育类目录，而女性通常是那种常规的时尚模特。T台模特被选中是因为她们个子高，能穿T台服装。而男性只需要身材健壮就行。他们个子不高，身材敦实且肌肉发达。
So we want the big muscle chest because that's what the ladies are looking for. I got it. So my favorite anecdote of Chris is it was about this one particular shoot that she did for a clinch cover. One specific time like you know we got these male and female models and they were very timid with each other you know they didn't want to touch. This was a contemporary, very hot. This was during the time of 50 shades of gray, so the content was very hot and sexy.
所以我们需要那种大块头的肌肉胸肌，因为那是女士们所追求的。我明白了。关于克里斯，我最喜欢的一个轶事是关于她为言情小说封面拍摄的一次特定经历。有一次，你知道，我们找来了男女模特，他们彼此之间非常害羞，你知道，他们不想有身体接触。那是一次现代风格的拍摄，非常火辣。当时正值《五十度灰》流行的时候，所以内容非常火辣性感。
They were acting like they were giving the church hug. Like this and I was like, oh my God, I'm gonna have to really go in. Well, I never really thought about it, but the models have most likely strangers when they come in. Yeah, they are. And I think sometimes they know what kind of shoot they're going to do, and sometimes they don't even know that.
他们表现得就像在进行教会式的拥抱。就像这样，我当时心想，天哪，我真的得亲自上阵了。嗯，我从来没想过这个问题，但模特们来的时候很可能都是陌生人。是的，他们确实是。而且我觉得有时候他们知道自己要拍什么样的照片，而有时候他们甚至连这个都不知道。
Oh my God. Yeah. And that was the situation with this couple that Chris just mentioned. They didn't feel comfortable with each other at all. The photographer, I tend to work with, he was really good at setting mood. So his scene would turn down the lights. We would get a lot of people off the set, put on the right kind of music.
天哪。是的。这就是克里斯刚才提到的那对情侣的情况。他们对彼此一点也不感到自在。我通常合作的那位摄影师，他非常擅长营造氛围。所以他的场景会调暗灯光。我们会让很多人离开片场，播放合适的音乐。
We got some R&B, we got some old motel, you know. And so, about an hour in, they started to really started to relax. So we set up, you know, a bedroom scene, and so there's a bed, and they're laying on the bed and we're shooting above. So we're looking down on them and they're like laying on the bed and we're getting that shot with their bodies and tangles our hair. It's like, you know, all of the place body ended the shoot. I could not stop them. Like it had gotten that high. This is between you and I and the other people who are listening.
我们放了一些R&B，还有一些老派的摩城音乐，你知道的。大约一小时后，他们开始真正放松下来。所以我们布置了一个卧室场景，有一张床，他们躺在床上，我们从上方拍摄。所以我们俯视着他们，他们躺在床上，我们捕捉到了他们身体纠缠、头发凌乱的镜头。就像，你知道，到处都是身体，拍摄结束了。我无法阻止他们。那种程度已经很高了。这是你我以及其他听众之间的秘密。
I had to we the photographer and I would go and okay, that's it. It's a wrap. It's a wrap and they would like I mean going in. Between you and I and the rest of the people who are listening. Yeah you're right she really kind of needed her own episode. Truly like someone give her a podcast. Well, thank you, Katie. That was so interesting. The whole episode, I just absolutely loved it. I love that it comes from you and your mom too. That's the greatest part of it all. Well, thanks, Roman. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Katie Minkle edited by Emmett Fitzgerald, mixed
我不得不和摄影师一起去说，好了，就这样。结束了。结束了，他们还是……我的意思是，他们完全沉浸其中。这是你我以及其他听众之间的秘密。是的，你说得对，她真的需要有自己的节目。真的，有人给她开个播客吧。嗯，谢谢你，凯蒂。这太有趣了。整个节目，我绝对非常喜欢。我喜欢这来自于你和你妈妈。这是最棒的部分。嗯，谢谢你，罗曼。《99%隐形》本周由凯蒂·明克尔制作，埃米特·菲茨杰拉德剪辑，混音
by Amida Kanatra, music by a director of sound Sean Rihau. Our senior producer is Delaney Hall, Kurt Colstead is the digital director, the rest of the team includes Vivian Leigh, Joe Rosenberg, Christopher Johnson, Lashemma Dawn, Chris Baroube, Sophia Klatsrand, and Vivian Stevens. If you'd like to know more about Katie's mom's books or read Sarah McLean's romance about lockpicking inspired by an episode of this very show, or listen to the incredibly charming podcasts that Nicole Perkins has hosted or or browse through Prince of Mexicans, Briggs Classic Vintage Clinch cover paintings. Well, we'll tell you how
由阿米达·卡纳特拉负责，音乐由声音总监肖恩·里豪创作。我们的高级制片人是德莱尼·霍尔，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监，团队其他成员包括薇薇安·李、乔·罗森伯格、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、拉谢玛·道恩、克里斯·巴鲁贝、索菲亚·克拉茨兰德和薇薇安·史蒂文斯。如果你想了解更多关于凯蒂妈妈的书籍，或者阅读莎拉·麦克莱恩受本节目某一集启发而创作的关于撬锁的浪漫小说，或者收听妮可·珀金斯主持的那些极其迷人的播客，或者浏览布里格斯经典的复古言情封面画作。嗯，我们会告诉你如何
to do all of that at 9ipey.org. We are a part of the Stitcher and Serious XM podcast family. Now headquartered six blocks north in beautiful uptown Oakland, California. You can find the show and join the discussions about the show on Facebook. You can Beautiful, Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join the discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI Ork. We're on Instagram and Reddit too. You can find 444 old but still amazingly relevant episodes
做到这一切，请访问99pi.org。我们是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一员。现在总部位于加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心以北六个街区。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIOrg。我们在Instagram和Reddit上也有账号。你可以找到444集旧但仍然非常相关的节目
of this show and other shows I love from Stitcher on our website. It's 99pi.org. I think Stitcher knows they bought us. Like it was in the New York Times and everything. Here we go. Da da, da da, da da, da da, da da, da da, da da, da da, da da, da da, da, da, da, da, Da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及我从Stitcher上喜欢的其他节目，请访问我们的网站。网址是99pi.org。我想Stitcher知道他们收购了我们。就像《纽约时报》上报道的那样。开始了。哒哒，哒哒……（此处省略重复的哒哒声）……目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。